i just didn't think i was ever gonna be  able to deal my way in no one's gonna  say you know we're gonna take a chance  for you kid i just never thought that  would ever happen and so out of  frustration i wrote reservoir dogs  because i just sold the script and i was  gonna take the money that i used to sell  this script and i was gonna make the  movie with that i mean i was gonna shoot  reservoir dogs for 30 thousand dollars  16 millimeter black and white that's why  it all takes place in one room i begged  him and begged him let me raise more  money and he refused no no no i've heard  that before forget it no way you know no  one's ever going to give me a chance and  then finally after like a long time he  goes into it give me two months with him  you can wait three months to make your  own movie give me two months with  i go okay  in two months we gotta  [Music]  that's what go